é emocionante subir num palco onde todo
mundo tem história para contar a minha
história desde criança é fazer arte com
o telefone que naquela época já era
móvel porque andava arrastando pela casa
hoje o meu propósito é ensinar e
aprender a fazer arte com o telefone
celular que está no seu bons no duplo
sentido de mostrar como isso pode
transformar a vida de muitos jovens
tudo começou em 2011
na tanzânia áfrica oriental quando fui
convidado a compartilhar o que já vinha
fazendo com o celular aqui no brasil
quando cheguei eu confesso a vocês que
não tinha a menor idéia do que fazer
então eu perguntei quem aqui têm
telefone celular e para minha surpresa
naquela sala de aula
todos tinham então eu pedi pra ver vocês
podem mostrar eu pedi pra tocar primeiro
lado esquerdo
depois do lado direito agora o meio e de
repente a gente estava gravando uma
sinfonia de celulares um conteúdo
espontâneo
um dos participantes dessa turma era um
guerreiro da tribo massai ele me
pergunta em sua rede
cacá bueno a facebook você sabe o que
significa isso
kaká significa irmão
o e cac no a colocar compartilhar e
fosse burro facebook irmão
vamos colocar isso no facebook naquele
momento eu entendi que a gente tem uma
ferramenta democrática nas mãos
estamos todos conectados nas plataformas
mas não sabemos o que fazer
que conteúdo produzir eu entendi que o
celular na escola não era um vilão
proibido por lei aqui no brasil
mas que podia ser uma ferramenta de
transformação de empoderamento de
inclusão digital e sobretudo de auto
expressão dos jovens
a propósito o lais aquele guerreiro da
tribo massai eu somos amigos hoje no
facebook e de 2011 pra cá a idéia se
propagou a experiência já aconteceu em
cinco idiomas em sete países
tânia etiópia israel-palestina marrocos
uruguai brasil e nós criamos um projeto
social que compartilha conteúdo pelo
celular através de uma simples 7 tag
arte mobile mas ninguém melhor para me
ajudar a contar essa história do que
aqueles jovens que não sabiam o que
fazer com ela
[Risadas]
[Música]
hoje todo mundo tá ligado a este
aparelho aqui ea gente não conservar o
poder dessa ferramenta que a gente tem
um bufo trancado a kinect andes e de
como o lixo mas não ligou lhe disse quem
o suíço ontem atinge debate os sete anos
sobreviveu
eu te mostro minha família ainda maior
eu não sei nós obviamente não se vê
variável se chamarmos a fifa
o dono do título se não tem cinemas o
futebol tentou e o pior é mesmo
confirmar a vitória por 2 a 1
assim o celular de outra forma não só
como meio de ligarem de educação de
comunicação da evolução dele naquele
começar a saltar
quem é detido a quem doer empenhar o
haiti nesta semana a opção de fazer a
partir de formada a esse companheiro
a diana possível detectar a sound wilks
e vendeu dele
sem isso formam paulo potthoff ou der
uma foto se vocês não acham pouco nem ia
ter que trabalhar é apropriada nas redes
sociais e também não visa nem estou
estender a emília press tv que é amado
pelo vício na via show linday cantor bob
casey james país
assim você tira aquela coisa de só falta
perfeita nítida e veio a o notebook
choca a coisa mais artística coisa
diferente quando joga
[Música]
essa ideia gente fazer arte com o
celular que está no seu bolso
obrigado gato explorar todos os recursos
se o seu celular tem câmera de vídeo
você pode fazer um stop motion como
esses participantes da palestina fizeram
um movimento anti tabaco e através das
fotos movimentada com os dedos
eles fizeram a animação tem câmera de
fotos a maioria tem você pode explorar
as cores do dia a dia você pode explorar
as sombras ângulos inusitados
você pode inclusive pintar com a câmera
de fotos do seu celular
brincando o movimentos rápidos
você pode explorar as cores e as luzes
a gente pode fazer música com o celular
esse artista de rua de desabar capital
da etiópia se inspirou e fez uma área só
com os tons do celular
e se você reproduzir essa numeração você
pode ouvir a música dele diz é muito
grande de moeda em nota
a liquidez é o leandro é v
[Aplausos]
o gent 99 por cento dos celulares tenha
sms através de mensagem de texto você
pode fazer roteiro poema coaching o
haicai estilo de poesia japonesa que
ultrapassou os muros do oriente médio
os participantes de israel e palestina
tiveram essa experiência trocando
mensagens de paz mas eu costumo brincar
e dizer que seu celular não tem câmera
de vídeo não faz foto está com um
probleminha de áudio sms não funciona
quebra esse celular ea gente usa as
peças recicláveis para fazer arte
mas a gente vai fazer arte e de quebra
levar uma consciência ambiental do mal
que essas peças podem fazer-se
espalhadas pelo planeta
bom tudo começou há uma pergunta que eu
vou repetir aqui esta noite
quem aqui têm telefone celular
eu posso ver vocês podem mostrar lhes
podem ligar na lanterna dos seus
celulares
vamos lá até desistir o celular do bolso
olha que bonito é isso que a gente pode
fazer juntos
eu deixo vocês com essa nova mensagem no
seu celular
muito obrigado valeu